[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est c'est une fête ce
campus c'est une occasion annuelle et
c'est bien que s'instaure ainsi des
traditions
euh marqué de du plaisir de se retrouver
mais il y a des moments
où le
monde ne nous laisse pas le choix des
sujets que nous devons traiter et comme
Ambroise mé Jean l'a dit
euh
naturellement au moment où nous sommes
engagé avec le président de la
République avec la première ministre
cher
isizabeth dans une action
gouvernementale dans l'application d'un
projet pour la
France à ce moment
précis le
monde bouge les
continents sont en train de d'entrer ou
de s'enfoncer dans un
toubouu qui nous met en face non
seulement de nos
responsabilités mais de nos
d'exister ce qui se passe depuis hier
matin en
Israël naturellement pour
nous à la signification première
de du refus et de la lutte contre le
terrorisme contre les les malheurs et
les
déchaînements
dont tant de victimes et tant de
familles de victimes sont depuis hier
atteint puis ce qui est atteint c'est
l'idée même de l'existence d'Israël et
des puissance qui se déchaîne autour de
cet état si symbolique du 20e siècle et
des 20 siècles 30 siècles précédents
euh
ceci
naturellement ajoute une vague de plus à
la tempête qui s'est
déchaîné
depuis que Monsieur Poutine a attaqué
l'Ukraine portant atteinte au principe
même sur lequel s'était fondé la paix
européenne et la paix du monde depuis
1945 et qui était le principe de
l'intangibilité des frontières on touche
pas aux frontières on va pas attaquer
les États voisins les forts n'ont pas le
droit d'attaquer les plus petits ou les
plus faibles c'est sur ça que c'était
construite la paix du monde et c'est ce
que Poutine a décidé de renverser et
derrière ces vagues ont eu des
conséquences que nous pressentions que
nous connaissions avec la remise en
cause des circuits de distribution de
l'énergie avec le lancement d'une
puissante tempête
d'inflation et tout cela nous en sommes
directement les victimes et
instantanément les regards se sont
tournés vers la Chine et vers les
menaces que Taïwan pourrait
ressentir et les sociétés notamment les
sociétés
occidental connaissent et ont connu des
déchirements je pense à la société
américaine si quelqu'un dans le monde
veut défendre la
bipolarisation je l'invite aller voir ce
qui se passe aux États-Unis et à
regarder ce que donnent deux partis tous
tenus chacun par leur noyau dur et qui
déchir la société et les consciences
personnelles et chacune des
familles c'était une parenthèse pour
nous faire plaisir mais euh et pour
faire plaisir à ceux qui depuis
longtemps comme Ambroise l'a dit se
battent autour de cette idée que la
démocratie c'est le pluralisme et ça
n'est pas l'affrontement d'un noir et
d'un blanc d'une d'une d'un d'un clan
contre un autre clan mais le le sujet
par lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui
naturellement
mobilisé c'est cette remise en cause
puissante de tout ce qui a fait le
développement du monde depuis des années
et depuis des
décennies
alors devant
cette débacle au
sens de ce terme qu'on emploie pour les
glacier lorsque ils fondent et que tout
d'un coup l'ordre n'existe plus devant
cette déb nous nous avons des
responsabilités sans
précédent nous avons des responsabil it
sans précédent parce que nous
sommes les voix ou les représentants ou
des voix et des
représentants de la France et de
l'Europe la grande question qui se pose
au fond la grande question à laquelle
Emmanuel Macron a
apporté une réponse ou un espoir de
réponse en 2017 c'est est-ce que le
modèle
français a un avenir ou bien est-ce
qu'il est destiné à s'éroder et à
s'effacer
comme tant de d'intervenants dans le
monde l'affirmer nous nous
pensons que cette
société
unique parce que elle est fondée sur le
principe de la solidarité à tous les
âges de la vie
depuis la maternité système de santé
en passant par l'école
maternelle en passant
par l'école primaire le collège le lycée
et jusque à ceux qui s'intéressent au
Collège de France éducation entièrement
prise en charge santé entièrement prise
en charge retraite garantie à tous
assurance chômage garantie à tous ce
système qui fait que tous dans la
société française nous avons décidé
d'être solidaire tous pour pour un et
pas comme les autres pays dans le monde
un système où c'est chacun pour soi
chacun qui pie son éducation chacun qui
piee sa retraite chacun qui pie sa
sécurité sociale et on vous demande
votre carte bleue votre carte de crédit
lorsque vous entrez à l'hôpital nous
avons construit un système unique dans
le monde nous nous croyons et affirmons
que ce système a de l'avenir et que il
est pour nous le principe d'organisation
et nous devons l'affirmer contre tous
ceux de tous les bords et notamment les
extrêmes qui plaident pour que ce
système soit renversé ou en tout cas
suffisamment changé pour qu'on ne le
reconnaisse
plus et nous avons pour défendre ce
système et dans le moment politique que
nous vivons une certitude
c'est que jamais dans l'histoire et
jamais dans le monde jamais dans
l'histoire et jamais dans le monde les
extrêmes n'ont apporté au peuple quelque
chose qui ressemble à la sécurité de
l'avenir et à la sérénité de l'envie de
vivre
ensemble et nous savons c'est mon
dernier mot que pour
porter l'idéal français le projet
français nous n'avons pas d'autre arme
que la construction d'une Union
européenne solide
inventive déterminé qu'il n'existe aucun
autre chemin pour un peuple comme le
nôtre dans le tu dans la tempête du
monde que de faire front ensemble et
c'est bien ce que nous allons montrer
nous sommes les seuls à pouvoir le
montrer au moment des élections
européennes qui viennent et dans les
nous porterons ce message qui n'a aucun
équivalent merci d'être ensemble